5 25 and your Monday morning what's
driving you crazy you want to hope for
the best but prepare for the worst
because this is just the beginning we're
talking about the first of several
months of repaving the Las Vegas Formula
One race track on and around the strip
started last night scheduled to run
through Friday wanted to show you a live
picture of Sands between Las Vegas
Boulevard and Howard Hughes is actually
at Koval one of those streets that has
three different names okay so west of
the strip it's known as Spring Mountain
East of paradise it's known as Twain but
in between it is Sands and it's uh well
there might be some open lanes between
the strip and Hughes Parkway may be a
good idea to be prepared for a complete
closure at times maybe plan on
navigating the lane restrictions on
desert in between Valley View and
Paradise where at least you know you can
get through so the official Formula One
webpage describes the repaving as roll
enclosures that's supposed to mean an
open lane or two but is that worth a
headache of maybe finding out the hard
way we are keeping an eye on it for you
but we want you to buckle up and drive
carefully and please put down that phone
you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com